investors should buy real assets from
wine to art as
inflation reaches a secular turning
point bank of america says
a story by business insider since the
election
president joe biden inflation and its
potential comeback
has been a hot economic topic pumping
trillions of dollars into the economy
could overheat critics say while others
see few signs of runway inflation either
now or near future bank of america chief
investment strategist
michael hartnett has seen enough to
declare a
secular turning point on inflation and
anticipates that stock market
returns will be lackluster over the next
decade let me read that one more time
this is not an employee at bank of
america this is not a director
this is not an advisor this is not an
accountant this is the chief
investment strategist michael hartnett
has seen enough to declare a secular
turning point on inflation anticipates
that stock market returns will be
lackluster over the next decade stock
investors who've seen
a roughly 10 percent annual return from
recent decades
should expect that gain to go down to
three to five percent over the course of
2020s he added but he has a
recommendation
buy real assets such as real estate
commodities and even collectibles like
wine art diamonds
cars could outperform in the next decade
you know what this is
this is collectibles these are things
that you cannot duplicate you cannot get
another
grace kelly psa 10 1955 card you can't
duplicate these things right the chance
of that happening is slim to none
so investors don't need to own the
physical assets hartnett added but
instead can own
reits real estate investment trusts and
specialized funds that focus
on these assets so he's p he's saying
the next decade if you read it right
land is going to go up real estate is
going to go up anything that you can
just
print is going to go up tom i'm going to
go to uh first on this story what are
your thoughts
you agree with them okay b of a's alter
ego in the investment banking world on
wall street is
goldman merrill lynch merrill lynch yeah
yep so
that's right they bought them out like
in 11 years ago or 10 years ago and it
just so happens we have a reit and a
specialized fund that we could help you
out with this
so there's a little bit of there's a
little bit of retail sale here going on
but i think he's right
because he's he's describing
a simple analysis if inflation goes up
and these returns go to three to five
over here then your return could be
you know 10 over here i think that's a
really
sliver of a of a gap there but you know
i
i don't disagree with it and i think
with inflation i
think you know the collectibles
that are not in infinite supply i think
that works
i you know it's an i think it's a valid
investment strategy but it's one of many
strategies
yeah i think um i'll take this with a
grain of salt this is one guy there's
going to be
other analysts that are going to say put
your money in the stock market are you
crazy this is
so i think the a couple key lessons for
all our friends out there watching this
is
number one diversification so should you
be in the stock market
a resounding yes should you have all
your money in the stock market maybe not
maybe you should diversify
and have some reits like for instance
i'm very big i rent i think i've been
very vocal about that i don't buy
houses i just kind of keep it moving and
i'm very flexible and i move from miami
to boca to dallas but it's a lifestyle
choice it's a lifestyle choice obviously
when i have kids and i settle different
story it's a different story but i might
even still rent at that point sure
but i'm all in on the stock market and
i've things have done very well over the
last decade
and change um but should you put
us you know a sliver of your money in
reits maybe ten percent sure should you
put ten percent of your
five to ten percent of your assets into
crypto sure but the bulk of it should be
in the stock market in my opinion
whether it's a 40k
401k should be in the stock i think so
yes
i think so yes because again building
average investors yes or even the i mean
for everyone but like don't forget
building wealth is
a marathon not a sprint we talked about
the 18 year old getting into debt yes
trying to get rich quick and then i
think it worked out pretty well for you
um but it's a marathon not a sprint the
goal if you're 18 or 21 or 25 is to get
rich by 30
it's i just think an 18 year old can
take a lot more risk well clearly you
should
the right experience for an 18 19 20
year old is like well you can bounce
back a lot of years yeah that's why they
say that if you're just
not the dumb big mistake well not you
cannot not going backwards
no not well i got into dead 49 i mean i
was into dead non-stop is what i was
into so
but what i'm saying to you is not the
dumb mistake you can't make a dumb
mistake the dumb mistake is
you get caught something that you know
gets you a felony or something that
hurts you to go into business or your
record things like that
all the others you can lose all the
money in the world if you're younger not
all the money in the world but you can
lose some money because you can recover
from it of course
but but you're saying like getting
arrested
having a mark on your record like
selling selling
you know drugs just to make money i'm
not talking about it play the long game
with that so i don't want anybody quote
me and say pat you said
anything to take the risk i'm not saying
that here's my last point
i believe in something called the kiss
principle keep it simple stupid so
we've talked sort of the theme of this
podcast so far is do your research you
know
find out what's going on out there so
they're giving you a lot of
recommendations of where you can kind of
put your money whether it's real estate
commodities
collectibles wine art diamonds like i
don't know anything about wine
other than if i'm gonna have a glass of
dinner yeah i'll take the cab cool
i'm not gonna become a wine investor i
don't know anything about art i'm not
gonna become an
art investor so i do know about
basketball i do know about the nba so
yeah i'd put 10 grand on a
zion williamson card because i
understand that marketplace
i understand hard assets like
real estate but i'm not trying to buy a
property so that's my big advocate of
reits
real estate investment trusts with
people out out there that aren't
familiar with
with that but diversify but i would say
regardless of your age fifty percent if
not more
of your core shouldn't be in the s p 500
this guy is telling you to to look you
know how you say hey
you know what he's doing is he's selling
because it's merrill lynch and all that
right
okay let's just say yes he is but but
tom
i think he's observing and selling but
but i think if you read it the guy says
real real real assets such as real
estate commodities and even collectibles
like wine art diamonds and car
could outport outperform in the next
decade those are none of the products he
sells
if you like he's not selling wine he's
not selling art he's not selling
diamonds he's not selling cars
that's not what b of a specializes in he
is selling
not selling away it's a bad term for the
financial industry but he's selling
to a different direction and imagine if
you're one of his advisors and you're
sitting there saying
why are you as a chief investment
strategist talking about mine what i can
make money on how do you want me to make
commission so i can get your money back
to you you think he's facing backlash no
what i'm saying is
i like his honesty i like the fact that
he's act because most of the time when
he like i go to you know these events
with goldman sachs and the chief
economist will speak and all these guys
will speak
they'll typically give you whatever
recommendation and you know you know
what i'm talking about don't tell the
company
but but i like the fact that i don't
know him i've never met him i don't know
his story i don't know his background
for all i know is he could be you know
someone who's against capitalism but
pull up michael hartnell yeah but but
all i can say is the fact that he's
selling
this the way he's saying cars diamonds
art and wine there's some integrity in
it and what he's saying that's all
he's saying cars he didn't i think cards
but cards i didn't say cars cars
right which i mean i don't know what
kind of cars these are for let me talk
about classic cars
tom why don't you tell us tell us how
much money is made in in cars
collectible cars like literally
crazy crazy classic we're talking about
classic crazy
you put a line for the s p 500 and you
put a line for collectible ferraris
the ferraris are crushing it sam heart
just crush art
i'm sorry tom keep going you were saying
no if you looked at ferraris
just as a from the 1950s 60s and 70s
just look at those
those vehicles and look at them say as
an s p 500 and the ferrari market letter
which is almost wikipedia the stock
market for that
it is phenomenal the money you've made
on that and so you can go get smart
about it
you don't have to own it you can with a
consortium you can own them
it's just amazing by the way also this
this guy
how do we know that he he was honest
with what he said this is a business
insider story so
how much of all this did he expect to
see in print was that an offhand comment
that he made
talking about inflation and he makes an
off-hand comment about cars and stuff
and it puts it in print
and then meanwhile business insiders
while she said the story well that part
was off the record i wasn't supposed to
say that i was talking about the
yeah the other things well it is what it
is you know what's really interesting
about the stock market
i saw something somebody asked me and
said look how do i how do i learn about
stock market i said look don't worry
about it
stock market's got a risky side and
stock market has a more conservative
side that has a lot less risk
and one of the best things i saw was um
you know five twenty nines what's a 529
that's a college
college college savings plan and so who
buys into college savings plans moms and
dads
right who might not know anything
about it other than maybe they have a
pension but the pension is managed by
somebody else
so they may not be retail investors with
any sort of knowledge of stock market
there's this great analysis that said
the closer your child gets to college
you can just click the box here and we
will reduce the risk in your 529 sort of
like a target date fund that they do
that's exactly right
but but again these people don't know
what that means
but it was a beautiful explanation that
says hey the risk here at kindergarten
is going to be here but we're going to
be reducing the risk the closer they get
to college
because although there is still risk in
this fund there's still risk of loss
the closer we get to college we want to
turn down the market risk that's our job
that's what you're trusting us to do
and then you read this thing and i'm
like when i first saw that i think it
was t.i.a cref did it
i said wow what a great explanation for
parents
that let you walk away saying okay this
is how the 529 is going to roll
and also it was a primer on being in the
stock market but not
everything is just throwing darts at the
wall mm-hmm i like that well
i think with anything with investing
much like in anything with life it comes
down to risk versus reward right
so something that i when i was like i
don't know how to invest i don't know
when i was in my early
mid 20s i learned about the 80 20 rule
the closer you are to age 20 the more
you can have 80 in stocks 20 in bonds
the closer you are to 80
more closer to 80 bonds 20 stocks
so depending on your age like pat like
said when he said uh when he was in
18 years old he took on a lot of debt
you have time to bounce back you can
take on more risk
not dumb risk not getting arrested not
out there selling drugs not getting in
stupid fights or anything like that
but the younger you are can take on more
risk the older you are if you're in your
80s
you shouldn't be in 100 equities you
should be in more likely 80 or 90
bonds and less stocks so everything in
life comes at risk and reward and just
like the 529 plan
when someone's in kindergarten they've
got 18
you know eight no not 18. 12 plus years
to
for their money to grow i did some basic
math there versus if they're a
sophomore less time to make their money
grow
well i'll loop one more thing around
nfts because that's where this
part of this segment started is i don't
see any difference in what's happening
in
nft's first issues right now from ipos
there are ipos that come out and they're
a little bit rust it's a weaker company
but they have this amazing first day and
then they settle and then they all come
back
some of my last couple case studies were
companies that i showed hey well look
they had this huge huge pop came down
but then they stuck discipline
discipline discipline
growth growth growth profit profit
profit and the price comes back up
i think that's you're seeing that with
nfts wow i love basketball
you know lebron james only making a
hundred versions of that one dunk his
first official nba dunk oh my goodness
pop well i think over time there's still
only 100 of those
so i think the value will come back so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye